responding to questions from members of
parliament
the session was mainly about his
priorities on economic development
but the crisis in tigray was also big on
the agenda
what's the future relationship between
the federal government and the tplf
can there be sustainable peace and
tigray and is there the possibility of
time forces taking their fight beyond
the tugran borders
the prime minister gave more reasons why
the military was deployed to the region
last
november saying the tigrayan forces had
an expansionist agenda to destabilize
the country
they prepared an army but they didn't
stop there they started encroaching on
the rest of ethiopia and started to
destabilise the entire nation in all
sorts of ways
this is quite dangerous and at the end
of the day it would endanger the
existence of the nation
it's considered as a threat
the government declared the war over in
late november but things have changed
the rebels have retaken the capital
macaulay and other areas in the region
what i think was less expected was
the speed with which the tdf transformed
itself
from a mobile dispersed
guerrilla force into almost a
conventional army that just
marched not only on matele
the humanitarian situation is dire the
u.n says more than 400 thousand tigrans
are now suffering from farming
electricity and telephone lines
have been cut the air space is closed
and infrastructure including important
bridges have been destroyed
salman ali say a political dialogue is
necessary
but does not appear possible just now
the government
doesn't recognize the tdf as a
legitimate authority into grey
doesn't even seem to accept that it
exists and the tdf
says it doesn't want bilateral talks
with the government it
believes that a national dialogue is
necessary to save ethiopia so i think
we're far from anything beyond
an immediate humanitarian truce if that
the tigran leadership and its political
party tplf
has given a list of demands for a
ceasefire it wants among other things
the federal government to recognize it
as a legitimately elected regional
government of tigray
that may be difficult the administration
of prime minister abi ahmed
has already labeled tplf and its forces
a terrorist organization catherine soy
al jazeera
addis ababa